next week for the fifth fifth year in a
row we're taking our show down to San
Diego for comic-con
[Applause]
we'll be airing nice it's become like a
real tradition for us we're gonna be
airing a week of shows from the historic
Spreckels theater down there we've got a
lot of exciting stuff planned and
incredible guests lined up plus some
really cool surprises and surprise
guests you do not want to miss it's all
happening it's a little different
Wednesday July 17th through Saturday
July 20th be sure to watch those shows I
think they're gonna be great they're
gonna be really
I gotta tell you I envy and II probably
the thing I get most jazzed about with
comic-con is seeing the fans oh they're
the best part absolutely me down yeah we
always have a blast there yeah every
time we go oh here we go okay I'm the
hell was that sorry
sir what's the problem here we go with
the comedy bits making fun of all the
nerds down at comic-con right no no not
at all I don't think we do that every
year we embrace the culture and various
communities present at comic-con
they really do you're just setting me up
typical straight male aggro stuff no I'm
telling you we respect the fans at
comic-con they come to our shows and
they enjoy them okay oh okay I get it
you're threatening to kick my ass no I'm
not I'm not ready to do that at all yes
you want to give me a wedgie
don't you Coco no I don't want to give
you a wedgie
I do like it's okay it's fine I'll save
you the trouble
hey don't don't do that
oh why it's not humiliating enough for
you what do you want to give me a swirly
fine
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
don't worry folks it's just toilet water
what is there a toilet in the aisle
anyway would you do me a favor stop
bullying yourself this is ridiculous
why tough guy not enough for you huh I
know what you bullies want you want to
get rid of me but don't worry I'll do it
myself
you see you
I don't know what his deal is that was
completely unnecessary and I'm just
gonna move on okay something exciting I
have two free tickets to our first
comic-con show
hey what listen up they go to the person
in seat eight j8j Oh Lyman AJ I mean AJ
that's me they're my tickets okay well
that seat is empty let's get out let's
give it to the person in seat seven j 7j
please yeah that's me oh my gosh this is
so cool
thanks bro now they're my tickets that's
not fair they're my tickets
shut it nerd you're dead all right to
request tickets for one of our live
tapings from comic-con in San Diego
visit team koco.com slash tickets and
you can get him there with a break